do you want to live a long and healthy
life would you like to know how to
achieve that result I'm Jill huet brain
Fitness expert and wellness Authority
and I'm here with my good friend and
colleague Dustin widger we're here to
put the lens on this very important
matter that's relevant to all of us
healthy
longevity in just a short amount of time
we're going to bring in our mentor and
friend world-renowned Health and
Longevity expert Dr Joel wallik but in
the meantime to get started how about
you share a bit about your background
Dustin because I know you love what you
do and you're very good at it well thank
you very much Jill yeah so for those who
don't know I'm a certified fitness
clinician and a holistic health coach so
I help those that want to recover
transform optimize their physique and
overall holistic health through
prescribed exercise nutrition and
mentorship guidance support
accountability all those things and uh
this doc Wallock message is something I
really try and include in that for sure
it's so important it's so important and
clearly we're passionate about the same
things educating and empowering people
on how they can make positive healthy
lifestyle changes so so Dustin doesn't
it sadden or shock you how many people
are just hoping praying crossing their
fingers that they don't become the next
statistic uh relating to premature aging
and disease absolutely I mean definitely
saddens me it doesn't shock me um
general population is is kind of been
brainwashed into the whole medical
system thing and it's it's kind of
coming out more and more now but you
know this generation we've been exposed
to a lot of propaganda I mean I saw the
other day the same thing you turn on the
TV you know we're we're around the
corner from the next from The Cure you
know and they show a little science clip
with you know a bunch of medical
professionals under the microscope and
doctor comes on who's a specialist and
it's very authoritative and and and
pretty you know and it seems like okay
they're very convincing but but you know
we spent $2.3 trillion in healthcare and
in one year that's what America spends
and they're the leaders in modern
medicine right so um spent all this
money and we're we're 92nd in
healthfulness okay 60th in longevity and
41st in survivability of our newborns
okay and this is this is pretty tragic
and uh you know third world countries
have better numbers than that even the
centenarian ratio um in North America in
industrialized nations one in every
10,000 people live above 100 in these
thir world countries one in every 500
person is above a 100 so they're doing
traditional stuff and doing fine we're
doing all this fancy stuff and suffering
because of it like heart disease is
number one still caus a death for the
past 100 years you know cancer is still
number two so obviously chronic disease
is isn't working out so well you know
from from North American perspective it
doesn't say a lot for modern medicine
and and there are uh much easier and
more effective results and that's why
I'm so excited about this conversation
and the information we're covering
because it's time people had solutions
that they can Implement and that work
well when you start to give the body
what it needs it can do amazing things
and you know this is more of what I like
to call Common Sense uncommonly
practiced and uh what better person than
yourself and uh interviewing here with
Dr Joel wallik Nobel Prize nominee
winner recipient of a Lifetime
Achievement Award and uh yeah sharing
his knowledge and research because it's
outstanding absolutely I can't wait I
mean I've got to meet doc a few times
asked him a million questions and now we
decided to get it on camera because this
is something that can benefit us all and
you're not going to hear about this on
the mainstream news Okay Doc's kind of
competition for the big companies right
and uh and good competition so so if you
want you know if you want you know to
help yourself this is this is a step one
in help it's the number one big one and
uh you know I've had the opportunity to
interview doc wallik several times on my
Wellness TV show years back and it was
always very enlightening educational eye
openening we always learned and took
away a lot and so this time around I'm
going to pass the mic over to you so you
can lead the interview with them and I
know it's going to be fantastic well I
can't wait appreciate it so
[Music]
much okay we are here with the legend
himself Dr Wallock thanks for coming in
man well thank you Dustin appreciate it
yeah I appreciate you coming down Jill
set us up here and uh we got lots of
questions I want to just kind of give a
broad you know sure picture for for
people that haven't heard of yet but doc
you tell us a bit about yourself your
background and and sure okay Justin the
thing that makes me different I think is
I have a degree in agriculture my majors
in animal husbandry and nutrition my
miners in fuel crops and soils I have a
degree in veterinary medicine I also
have a postal Fellowship was the
equivalent of a PhD degree in compared
pathology doing OD topes in animals and
people
and then um I do have a degree in
naturopathic medicine I've been a
naturopathic physician since 1982
licensed primary care physici and so I
have those four aspects which I draw
from anytime I talk to somebody or um
try to figure out a patients's health
problem and decide what to give them so
I'm a little bit different than an MD or
an ND or a do or chiro prer so you
really have a uh broad perspective
obviously exactly and it's all about
nutrition all ties together right so
well yes they did one big project with
the National Institutes of Health back
in the 60s and
70s and in that project it did 20,000
autopsies 177,000 some change over over
454 species of animals and 3,000 humans
and 10 million chemistries looking for
pollution problems and the basic gist of
that study was that every animal every
human being that dies of what we would
call natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficient disease and we
learned that all vertebrates whether
you're a human being or a crocodile or a
hummingbird or a turtle or a fish or an
elephant requires 90 cents nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 amino acids
Three fatty acids and you get those
things you reduce your risk of diseases
and you live longer you don't get those
things you increase your risk of disease
and you die earlier wow okay so skipped
ahead a bit there I want to go right
into that um how did you get that
project you know before before what was
your career you know comparative
pathology started before that right and
then why me yeah yeah okay that's why I
asked myself um well prior to going to
University during the summer times I
used to work with Marlon Perkins from
the old meaha Wild Kingdom show you're
probably too young remember that show
but he was the he was the biologist on
TV before the crocodile hunter okay okay
and so I worked for him maybe five six
years during the summer times and when I
graduated agricultural school I was
already into two years of veterinary
school and so I was a graduate student
even though I had two years of veter
school left I began to take compared
pathology courses towards my PhD degree
which turned out to be a post-doctoral
fellowship and I ran into the first mass
die off of pollution in America how
people had theorized it and they they
predicted it but somehow it landed in my
lap did all the chemistries got a
published in peerreview referee
scientific journals actually run around
the states and the world lecturing on it
because I was the first guy to discover
it gave Perkins a copy of it because he
was one of my first male mentors who is
not a
relative and he helped me get a job in
Africa working in the white Rano
conservation project and the African
elephant conservation project caught 200
white Rano sent them back to the States
so if you see a white rno in a zoo or
wild animal park it's either one that I
caught or offspring that I caught moved
a hundred of them around in Africa and
um caught 100 elephants anal elephants
and coold branded them to track their
movements up was really into these large
animal conservation
projects well two years into that
Perkins sends me a letter said wallic I
just got a big Grant from the National
Institutes of Health to study pollution
as a contributing cause of death in
animals uh in big zoos in the United
States and Canada and Mexico in North
America we're looking to see if
pollution uh is a contributing factor to
non-infectious diseases non um epidemic
diseases things we think of as being
natural causes and you're the guy you
wrote the first paper on a mass out in
American Revolution so we're picking you
to be the pathologist on the project of
course I was wow so I said I can always
go back to Africa so I'm going to take
this job went back I worked for 12 years
on it did my 20,000 autopsies 10 million
chemistries and the book that came out
of it 12200 Pages covers all these
autopsies and all the chemistries and
the work showed that every animal and
every human being that dies of natural
causes you know not trauma not
infections but just heart disease liver
disease lung disease brain disease that
kind of stuff that are attributed to age
or genetics or
autoimmune uh those diseases are all
caused by nutritional
deficiencies so this this whole thing
with Marlin Perkins I mean how did he
get that Grant I'm curious how that hold
tie that tie together like that well St
Louis of course had a high profile
because of his association with the um
mutual m Kingdom show but it wasn't too
far really right across the highway from
Washington
University and a very well respected
University Medical School Barnes
Hospital teaching
hospital and um he and the head of the
biology Department there a fellow by the
name of Barry keter who actually run for
president on the Independent party
several times on on the basis of saving
the environment you know eliminating
pollution this sort of thing those two
guys together applied for a grant to
study um animals the DI natural cause in
the big zoos in North America and people
who live within a 10 m radius what they
wanted to do is use the zoo animals as
the old Welsh coal miners used to use
canaries you know the canary in the mine
story where the Welsh coal miners would
take the canaries out in the mine and if
gases would leak into the mine they were
either toxic or they would suffocate you
or explode um the canaries would die
first and they'd see the canaries drop
off the perch and die they would
flee yeah they would they would flee and
were able to survive well Perkins had
the very good idea that if we did the
same thing but using zoo animals uh
there's 400 500 600 species of zoo
animals big zoos in big cities there's
bound to be a couple of species that
would give us an early warning of
pollution imminent danger from pollution
and since I wrote the first paper in a
MK out from pollution they wanted me to
be the guy pathologist in the project so
pathology can we mean this big projects
awesome we're to get a bit more into
that but just talk about pathology
because I mean first of all is there not
a lot of people do this would you say no
it's a very small Club if you will um
and this is you know like a hospital
might have 200 Physicians surgeons and
general practitioners that work for the
hospital but there's usually one
pathologist okay and so it's a very
specialized um piece of the medical
system where somebody dies you go to
their house you pick up the body and by
law in most places you have to do an
autopsy to find were they murdered or
they have natural causes and so those
are the sort of things you learn to do
as
pathologist and um you also um learn the
causes of death of animals or people are
in
experiments they're either on drug
experiments for new drugs or nutrition
experiments or vaccine
experiments and in some cases at the end
of the study let see there's 50 animals
in the study have to kill them all and
then do autopsy see if the drugs or the
whatever vaccines caus any problems kind
of thing and so this is where as a
pathologist you have to know normal
Anatomy you have to know the normal
physiology you have to know the normal
biochemistry and you really have to know
more than a practicing physician you
take into account all the clinical
records and many cases the Physicians
would be treating for diseases the
patient didn't have but they died of
something the doctor didn't even know
they had because he was a bad
diagnos Pathologists no more than the
doctor than the practicing physician oh
yes absolutely and that's why like
pathology because you can always find
the answer there's no unknowns there's
also a I think I've read in epigenetics
there's a big difference
between animal autopsies and human
autopsies and that they leave out the
the cause of death or
something they don't explain that it's
deficiency in human beings they don't in
human beings they say died of a heart
attack yeah and everybody assumes as
natural causes in this any the other and
so in animals uh there's five different
types of heart attack we want to know
which one it is because each one is
caused by deficiency of a different
nutrient so why is that why wouldn't we
take it to the next level for humans
well medical doctors do not get one
minute of nutritional training eight
years of
school they have dietitians and
nutritionists for stuff like that that
low stuff they're into surgery and
pharmaceuticals really it's kind of an
ego thing you know this is something
that you know we don't need to know that
because that's something that
some dietician can know so right at the
top there they're you know they're
simply kind of just leaving out a very
important thing well of course because
nutrition is everything we cannot run
without nutrition now the interesting
thing to me Dustin is that every Century
there's thousands of failed medical
theories going back to the days of the
Pharaohs 5 six seven 8 thousand years
ago there's failed medical theories at
the rate of thousands per Century in the
20th century and 21st century are no
different all of the big medical
theories of today are false it's a
pretty profound statement but it's true
all the medical theories today that we
think of as guiding us to be healthy are
false um with all the technology we have
with all the new things that we brought
into medicine Americans are less healthy
than we used to be the scary thing is
our children children of your generation
my generation will be the first
generation Americans who do not live as
long as their parents most people will
be burying their children be standing at
gravide burying their children
so our age is going our life expectancy
is going down oh it's going down
yeah okay so this this big project let's
talk about that a little bit um you
basically LED this thing was a big think
tank of a lot of different scientists
right well they were biologists and they
were into the ecology out there in the
world looking for pollution right yeah
that was they were looking for sources
of pollution and they chose me to be
pathologist because I had written the
first paper on the first MK off in
America to be recognized and tracked
down and identify all the scenarios and
why it happened got a published
but I was the only pathologist so you're
kind of like the center guy right
exactly because if they' pick up a
roadkill on the highway and bring it in
it was a coyote or a deer I had to know
was the deer or the coyote hit by the
car because he had
rabies and was just out there being
stupid on the highway because he had
rabies affecting his brain or was he
being was the deer being chased by a
pack of coyotes or wolves and he was
fleeing and didn't pay attention what
was around and got hit by the car or um
was the deer did he have some kind of um
other debilitating thing that led him to
go out there in the highway or was it
just mating season and he was taking on
anything that invaded his territory did
a headon with the car I mean had to know
all these things um and so again they
accumulated the data for 17 ,000 some
change of death of over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 humans that book was
published in
1983 and it was published by the largest
medical Publishing House in the world WB
Saunders and the original price of those
books was $140 and everybody said you'll
never sell them because most textbooks
are being sold for 25 bucks 50 bucks and
they thought that was high but they sold
these for $140 and they sold 10,000 cop
two weeks and and
um yeah 10,000 books in two weeks now
today those same books if you can find
one on a used book sale
online if you get them where they're
covered in coffee stains and been
highlighted and dog eared and you know
underlined and so forth obviously been
used heavily you can find one for less
than $2,500 you better get it the ones
that are in perfect condition still in
the box have never been cracked you know
binding has never been cracked and open
they're selling for
$177,000 for each book this book is
called the diseases of exotic animals
correct the medical and surgical
management and it's 1200 page book
apparently you were supposed to do a
couple chapters and then ended up
writing the whole book or something well
yes I was supposed to write just a
couple of chapters of the 20 I think it
was I don't know 28 chapters and um uh
what happened was the other designated
authors each one was supposed to be a
specialist in the chapter on reptiles
another one's supposed to be a
author on small cage birds like finches
and canaries another one was supposed to
be a author on wild dogs like wolves and
coyotes and so forth in dingo in
Australia but it turns out they wrote
one paper from somebody who had a a pet
wolf and who died of something and they
wrote it up but that was it they had no
other experience well I had already
autopsy wild dogs I had already autopsy
several hundred and foxes and dealt with
the birth defs from nutritional
deficiencies in the female males while
they're pregnant developed into birth
effects in the babies and so I had all
that and chemistries and autopsies and
slides of special stains plus I'm a
veterinarian and I was it was very easy
for me to look up because we didn't have
computers in those days had to go to the
library and by hand looked through
thousands of books and and um journals
scientific journals looking uh for any
paper that's written on them and then
each chapter had to have the normal
blood values the normal
chemistry of the cereal spinal fluid the
fluid you know the vitus in the eye um
normal organ weights and colors and then
diseases they might get been
reported and um things to anesthetize
them safely so they could do surgeries
and how to prevent birth effects in
these animals and so on and so it's
quite a big project well the the Ed uh
the editings people and the um
Publishing Company call me say Okay w Dr
Soo is backed out because he doesn't
want to do all the effort necessary to
make this a respectable chapter would
you take this one yes 3 months lat said
hey this guy backed out and you know in
reptiles you know you've already
done maybe um 1500 autopsies on
different reptiles crocodiles and from
beginning right exactly but they wanted
it to be a multi-author textbook because
of was such a big project and they never
thought in their wildest dreams that one
person would have all that experience
and so I wound up with with the entire
book want you describe the Pathology Lab
we're going to get into disease and
stuff in a second but some examples of
like typical day or a couple couple jobs
that you do sure well the Pathology Lab
consists of many parts number one for
big animals you have to have you know
like a big double garage door would open
up and the trucks would back in and then
you had um hoist with on tracks so you
put chains around their legs and you
lift them up it might be 5 tons for an
elephant oh yeah or a Cale horse have to
lift them up tops you an elephant oh
many times yes sorry all ages and Rhino
and hippos and and all kinds of large
unul you know things like big Antelope
and giraffe think about a giraffe you
know they're 20 foot
tall that's not an easy job that's not
an easy job but when they're laying down
they're only 3 feet tall
and so um just about you know 454
species of animals uh you're talking
about a wide wide range everything from
shrews and Little Critters this big
couple inches long hummingbirds half
ounce all the way up to elephants 15,000
lb now in a little bitty hummingbird you
would use tweezers and a scalp a little
bitty
fingernail scissors an elephant you
needed an Axe and a
chainsaw had to use different you know
different tools for different jobs you
the fingernail fiss scissors wouldn't
work very well on a 15,000lb elephant so
you had to use different tools and and
then there was an immediate laboratory
there and you take samples of each of
the organs and you take photographs of
them and the colors and everything weigh
them and but the samples you would take
you'd put in from alahh and you'd
request certain stains because you're
suspicious of certain diseases you might
require a special stain to identify that
change and pass that into the laboratory
and I had technicians there who would
make slides for me I could look at it
under the microscope in the next 24
hours and then if it looked like they
had an infectious disease we would take
um swabs of the pus or the juice coming
out of the wounds or whatever and we
could culture it and see if it had a
bacteria virus fungus or Yeast we also
took the contents of the intestine look
for any parasites they might have check
that all out and even though there was
no changes let's say that the animal
might have died of um oh congested of
heart failure we still take the brain
and the spinal cord out look for any
changes in there to all the chemistries
so we're accumulating normal chemistries
as well as chemistries of diseases also
looking for pollution so we're taking
all the blood yeah we're looking at
every possibility and so each autopsy
was more than just opening up and say oh
he died of a heart attack and closing
him well each autopsy was a big project
in itself and so these 20,000
autopsies probably was the equivalent
time of doing a 100,000
autopsies because we spend so much yeah
because we did so much time on them even
the human beings that I autopsies um
were much more complete autopsies than
even a forensic pathologist for say for
the state or the county or something
like that and as a result I've been an
expert witness many times in state and
federal courts uh because few people
have the experience I have and when they
have these big complicated cases and the
results of the trial will be related to
the determination what you find and all
the tissues and and chemistries of that
autopsy I can tell them if there's
something missing if the tissues were
saved we had to go back and do all that
and add that to the material before you
know it could go to the juries and
things like this so I've been involved
in in quite a few things based on those
[Music]
on so this process I mean you didn't
invent this process so it's almost like
criminal that it's not this whole idea
of discovering what the disease is is
like talk about more and isn't in in
humans right that's correct that's
correct and of course um we talked about
these failed medical theories uh the big
ones um in human medicine are
cholesterol and saturated fat
contributing to cardiovascular disease
that's not true type two diabetes being
genetic that's not true autoimmune
diseases where your body's attacking
itself no that's
true birth defects are caused by genetic
defects no that's not true you're not a
fan of doctors are you well they' missed
things so badly and we spend more money
for healthcare each year than all the
other nations 204 Nations register the
United Nations we spend more money than
all those 204 Nations each year and we
rank 41st in live births and first month
survivability of our babies rank 60th in
longevity there's 59 other nations whose
peoples live longer than us there's
something wrong with this picture then
when you look at the other side of the
coin and this is from the Center for
Disease Control and the German American
Medical Association uh February 5th 2007
full page article in the USA Today they
said each year in America medical
doctors kill injure and infect 15
million patients in their Hospitals and
Clinics they kill injur infect 15
million patients in Hospital and Clinics
when you break it down a little bit they
infect 2 million people in hospitals
each year this from the Center for
Disease Control Federal agency not me
and of those 2 million infections 90,000
each year now there's no oosha tickets
given issued no doctor gets his license
suspended for 3
seconds and the reason why they got 2
million infections in the hospitals each
year according to the center of Disease
Control is doctors don't wash their
hands after they go potty something you
teach a three-year-old now here it
comes what if North Korea or Iran were
to send over an intercontinental
ballistic missile with a biological
weapon in fact
um two million people in large
population Center like
Toronto and killed 90,000 of those it be
War wouldn't it yeah it' be War I mean
even the most anti-war people would sign
off on war because they just killed
90,000 Canadians 90,000 that's each
year okay doc so essential nutrition
something you've been driving home so
can you talk about that a little more
what makes something essential how do we
know it's essential sure well first of
all all vertebraes again whether you're
a hummingbird or a crocodile or a human
being or an elephant or a rat or a dog
cat bird fish all requires 90 cent of
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
amino acids Three fatty acids and to be
identified uh and highlighted as an
essential
nutrient we cannot make we have to eat
them every day our body can't produce it
that's right we must eat them every day
either it's food supplements number two
if you're missing them for any length of
time you get a horrible
disease any one of which can kill you
okay that was proven in the lab of
course okay through like that was
through more animal studies and stuff
animal studies and you go back again
maybe in some cases hundreds of years
ago things like um rickets um
scurvy pelra berry berry night blindness
these things are all very simple
nutritional efficien diseases and these
were the first ones to be recognized as
nutritional deficiencies in the 1800s
where before that the theory was you
were caused by germs and doctors are
always looking for The Germ and they
couldn't fix it because it really
nutritional deficiency once they figured
that out we had those diseases disappear
well now they're all coming back they're
all coming back again because none of
these nutrients in our food
anymore and instead of playing outside
for instance uh little kids instead of
playing outside and playing tag and
hideand-seek during the day time after
school they're inside with their iPads
and iPods and iPhones they never go out
in the sun anymore and rickets is just
running a muck WR our K
now okay well let's get into um
different diseases here let's start with
heart disease okay and heart health in
general so many different causes the
heart disease okay well all heart
diseases are caused by um two things
99.9% of them are caused by nutritional
deficiencies and then there's an
inflammatory piece you know eating
microwave popcorn theer popcorn oils
cell dressings cooking oils fried foods
processed meets with nitrates nitrites
um cause inflammation in the
cardiovascular system let's just take
congestive heart failure one of the more
common causes a heart death in adults
caused by deficiency of a single vitamin
we've known that for 300 years
discovered by a Japanese Naval surgeon
300 years ago cardiomyopathy heart
disease sudden heart death in athletes
we lose about 10,000 athletes under the
age of 25 each year in America alone is
caused by deficiency of a single mineral
I've done 1,700 autopsies on kids under
the age of 10 that have died of that one
you said 10,000 athletes die a year yeah
in America alone 10,000 under the age of
25 yeah on the basketball court the
football field on the
tracki yeah these are the ones you see
in the newspaper they Dro dead in high
school or university wow that's a that's
a high number well coronary arter
disease um is actually caused by
inflammation things that happen by
eating trans fats hetocy comines
acrylamides has nothing to do with
cholesterol and saturated fat the
demonization of cholesterol and
saturated fat was done by the American
Heart Association in 1952 in exchange
for a $1.7 million Grant by Proctor and
Gamble and Proctor and Gamble wanted to
sell a product called krisco but they
had to demonize lard butter cream and
eggs because that's what grandma wanted
to use for cooking and so to get people
to switch over to krisco they had to
demonize what Grandma had been using for
500 or a thousand years and uh they also
had to uh make sure it was sexy and so
they came up with a mediterranian
diet oil yeah olive oil and why would
anybody want to live to be
62 okay that's the average lifespan of
an Italian or Greek in the
Mediterranean but all every woman wanted
to be ginola bridg so they made it sexy
by saying ah the Mediterranean
do now microwave popcorn is one of the
biggest sinful things of clogging
arteries that's why our children are
dying before we will now and people will
be bearing their children because they
babysit their children with microwave
popcorn and the TV when I was a kid I
grew up with four generations in my
household great-grandmother grandmother
mom and me there's no daycare there are
no babysitters we're eating our
traditional cultural diet that went back
thousands and thousands of years okay so
we didn't have the problems our kids
have today then the last one the
coronary thrombosis where you get a
blood clot in a coronary artery because
that's type of heart attack that's
caused an omega-3 essential fatty acid
deficiency one of the essential
nutrients are racial problem between
omega-3 six and N so which one of those
cardiovascular diseases are caused by
cholesterol and SRA fat not congestive
heart field vitamin deficiency cardi
heart disease and mineral deficiency
coronary Ary disease is inflammation and
coronary thrombosis is a deficiency
Omega-3s so nothing to do with genetics
either no genetics involved whatsoever
no what about people that say you know
obviously it's nature and nurture
but you know they're healthy but the
thing to go is their harder the thing to
go in that person is their brain you
think it's there's still a slight kind
of like a genetic predisposition no
nothing no okay yeah genetics are not
involved genetic gentics and cholesterol
are two of the biggest failed theories
of the 20th and 20th Century genetics
are not involved in any way it's
actually called
epigenetics okay how the environment
influences yeah exactly and basically
your genes your DNA your RNA and your
telr little end camps in the chromosomes
require all 90 essential nutrients 160
minerals 16 vitamins 12 amino acids
Three fatty acids and if any one of
those things is below the minimum daily
requirement are missing the genes of DNA
RNA and Tel can't work and so instead of
living be 200 and you're eating the same
recipe Grandma used when she ate and she
died at 120 you die at 18 of a heart
attack even though you're eating exactly
the same recipe for breakfast lunch and
dinner because everything changed
between Grandma's time and your
time wow okay so heart disease not
genetic easily preventable and easily
reversible if they survive the first
heart attack
[Music]
have you had good success stories of
people that are far down the line
you many many times about Vander
Holyfield can you help him with heart
problems well yeah sure he had a cardi M
the heart attack uh during championship
fight and this goes back gosh got to be
15 years ago great champ heavyweight
champion and um uh to make a long story
short we gave him all 90 cent of
neutrons a little bit of extra of the
secret sauce for heart health and he
recovered within 90 days he was able to
pass the physicals of all the boxing
commissions of every country on Earth
and went back and box professionally for
eight more years won and lost his
championship several times it's 100%
proof clinically right there yeah
exactly and so we do this with athletes
professional athletes with Olympic
athletes University and high school
athletes Little Pop Warner kids all the
time uh because people who work out and
are athletic need more nutrients than
somebody who's just a librarian sitting
in an air conditioned Library not doing
it
abely you're not you're not breaking the
system down at all you're not sweating
all that nutrient that's exactly
right you know I train people exercise
wise and like you said um some of the
people that are in the best shape often
are aren't in the best shape at the same
time that's right so let's talk about
maybe like a theor
pretty impressive result with him sure
well the r a great basketball player was
playing when I met him he was playing
for the Atlanta Hawks uh great
defenseman 611 just the ideal basketball
player and he um had bone to bone Earth
ring both his knees at age 28 just on
painkillers all the time and then the
cartilage popped off his right hip had
to be surgically tacked back down he
caught a pass from a teammate broke his
wrist just catching a pass in regulation
28 years old 28 years old yep and um of
course he was told his career was over
nothing be done rebuilt him with the 90
Cent just a little bit of secret sauce
to support maintenance repair of carag
and ligaments and bones and in 90 days
he was able to get his position back 90
days I was it it yeah and then he he
played basketball for another 14 years
he made $140 million in contracts after
the arth peak surgeons for the Atlanta
Hawk said his career is
over the best surgeons in the world
apparently that's what they tell you
yeah wow that's unbelievable how much
million 140 million do you think his
wife Christina loves me she
L unbelievable um what other athletes
did you work with oh Delicia Jones a
great uh woman basketball player uh she
uh was on the Women's Basketball team in
the Olympics for United States and she
was with them for their first two
Olympics and they had go gold medals in
both of them women's basketball just
they just a the Dream Team at women's
basketball in the Olympics and getting
ready for the third game for you know
four years later she tore her uh killes
ten and her hamstring on the right hand
side the arthop surgeons who put her
back together said you know look the
odds are you're not going to play with
the same skill level as you did before
you had this injury you might want to
consider coaching well she wasn't happy
about that and so a mutual friend
introduced me to her we rebuilt her in
90 days using the 90 cents of nutrients
the secret sauce for car's ligaments
tenons connective tissue
and she made her position back in the
team and she got her third gold medal
with them just really great great thing
so we do this all the time we do this
with um people who are Special Forces
Navy Seals impact injuries people in car
wrecks all kinds of stuff and even just
degenerative disease you know 99.9% of
the people that have bone to- bone
arthritis and their knees and hips they
don't need surgery and Joint
Replacements they just need the 90 Cent
nutrients the secret sauce body wants to
heal itself given they're all the right
materials it will heal
itself there's a lot of different
diagnosis for this for bone and joint
problems osteoporosis all the different
forms of arth it's all the same thing
doctor sure well just different degrees
has nothing do with age line yeah yeah
it has nothing to do with age has
nothing to do with gender has nothing to
do with genetics um very talking about a
osteoprosis ostearthritis deener
arthritis bone bone arthritis rheumat
arthritis bone spurs kidney stones
periodontal disease which is osteoprosis
in the face peripheral neuropathies
where you get all kinds of weird stuff
going on in your feet and hands and legs
and back because of degenerate disc
disease all that stuff is preventable
and it all goes away just with the 90
cents of nutrients and the secret sauce
so if you have born born arthritis no
cartilage I have a client that says he
feels like there screws in his knees he
can barely walk he can completely
rebuild up well the body body does that
we just give the body the raw materials
and it has the capacity to rebuild
itself body wants to heal itself but
your genes your DNA your RNA and your T
mirrors require these nutrients to be
able to pull it
[Music]
off okay so brain disease brain health
nervous system Health this encompasses a
lot of different things right well
Justin the brain requires all 90 sensal
nutrients like all the other TI in the
body it's incapable needs all 9 cental
nutrient 16 minerals 16 vitamins 12
amino acids Three fatty acids if any one
of those are missing get a disease and
we're talking about things like
depression mag depression bipolar
disease and bipolar disease when you're
in a uniform is called PTSD same disease
and then there's depression and there's
ADD ADHD autism there's psychosis
there's schizophrenia uh anxiety tax
panic attacks these are all caused by
nutritional deficiencies now the the big
one is Alzheimer's disease this is a
physician caused disease did not exist
45 years ago today it's number four
killer of adults over the age of
65 and it's caused by a deficiency of a
single nutrient
cholesterol who told people to get on
cholesterol restricted diets medical
doctors who wanted you to buy
krisco okay because they got paid $1.7
Million by proor and gamble to um
endorse krisco well um who told people
to get give up eggs and butter and cream
and lard medical doctors who began to
prescribe stattin drugs Allure
cholesterol medical doctors and then
Alzheimer's appeared that inhibits your
liver's natural ability to produce
cholesterol well your liver can produce
cholesterol but it's such an infantes
small amount I mean we're talking about
maybe of a quarter of a teaspoon a day
and you need maybe um a pound of
cholesterol a day so is that in lowering
drugs you don't think there that much of
an effect on it or oh no Stant Loring
drugs slam your cholesterol down way too
low and this is the cause of alcer
disease cholesterol deficiency is the
cause of alzer disease
now um you have to appreciate that
there's other deficiency diseases from
cholesterol deficiency too low t low
testosterone Ed erectile dysfunction um
women getting menopause in their 30s and
40s instead of 60s and 70s and adrenal
exhaustion why because adrenal hormones
estrogen progest testosterone those four
major stero um their steroid
hormones are all 95% by weight
cholesterol but it's adrenal glands uh
ovaries testes estrogen progesterone
testosterone andal hormones okay now
there's other hormones that are not
steroid hormones like pituitary hormones
thyroid
hormones okay okay let's lead into
fertility so how I mean obviously this
is 9al nutrients are important for that
too absolutely um and also to have a
healthy baby because all birth defects
are caused by nutritional deficiency to
developing EMB in the first 90 days of
pregnancy and I get more women pregnant
every year than Solomon they ever did
right and my wife is the first one to
jump and say well with nutrition right
um when women get miscarriages they're
not
infertile they were pregnant they just
couldn't handle the pregnancy okay and
so doctors would say give me
$25 give me
$25,000 and we'll give you an e in vitro
for ization they didn't need that they
got pregnancy you know having sex the
normal way right but doctors want to get
their
$25,000 they haven't dealt with the
problem so what you do is you get these
women on a gluten-free diet so they can
absorb nutrients and then you give them
the 90 cent of nutrient 60 Minal 16 voms
12 Three fatty acids they will always
get pregnant and the birth effects are
reduced almost zero now it always comes
down to absorption even if you're
supplementing with all 90 Central
nutrients but the mother has an
absorption problem because she has a
heavy gluten problem she's not avoiding
gluten she can still have a birth def on
her baby because she might not be able
to efficiently absorb the nutrients so
it's you mentioned it's dietary stress
and the essential nutrients that's
correct and you have to appreciate again
it's not what you eat you absorb what
you absorb you are not what it's an old
ad you are what you eat that's not true
you are what you absorb issues are a big
problem these days too obviously
[Music]
this is okay well type two type two Dias
makes up 98% of the diabetic
population we've known for 80 years that
type two diabetes is a deficiency of a
single
mineral we've known that for 80 years it
has nothing to do with genetics in any
way shape or form it doesn't just happen
with age it's a simple nutritional
deficiency and um I can make a family a
church family a neighborhood a workplace
and City a county a country diabetes
free in two months or less it's that
easy is that easy it's just like when
you have um iron deficiency nemia as a
patient would you want an iron
supplement or bone marrow
transplant doctors always go for the
bone marrow transplant so that's why
with diabetes they going to do all this
testing and they're going to give you a
pump and all this kind of stuff to
automatically pump the insulin in and
this and the other and really what you
need is the 90 cental nutrients 16
minerals 16 vitamins 12 amino acids
Three fatty acids and the secret sauce
for Di it all goes
[Music]
away okay no nothing about farming
practices have changed for 7,000 years
we plow we plant we Harvest we plow we
plant we harvest the only difference is
we're not getting the nutrients put back
in the cell because we've damned up the
rivers no more floods we're using
electricity no more wood and that was
all a myth blood thing is really key oh
that's big key big key and when you look
at the great cultures on Earth they came
up with pyramids and machinery and boats
and things you see the Nile River the
Amazon River the Ry
River okay you're looking at the
Mississippi
River all the big rivers in the world
all these great cultures developed
around them because every time the flood
would come they deposit more minerals in
the soil they grow their food there
wow prior to electricity we use wood for
fuel we put the wood ashes which are
really minerals that the trees sucked up
out of the ground into the garden and
the plants the pumpkins and tomatoes and
beans and peas and squash and and um
potatoes and onions and corn would suck
up these mins you ate the food and
unknowingly you got your minerals in
that way well when we went to
electricity nobody knew they were
getting minerals by eating food
fertilized with wood ashes and so nobody
replaced those sources and minerals with
minerals when you got electricity and
this was the downward spiral L we had
the Great Depression we had the Dust
Bowl people liked electricity and there
were factories and and things were
booming but there was an unintended
consequence does when they made
hydroelectric plants flood control
everybody thought that was the greatest
thing on earth flood control but that's
another Factor right there three or four
factors that affect the minerals right
yeah because what would happen every
spring in the most expensive and the
most fertile Farmland flood Plaines
Every Spring of flood flood waters
recede leave mud and silt which are the
minerals from mountains hundreds or
maybe even thousands of miles Upstream
did the farmer push the silt off to the
Cyber for planted no he plowed in
renewed the soil every year that's the
longest live cultures that's why they're
so successful right exactly right
because they're all third world cultures
they still use wood for
fuel wow wow so but the problem is
though even if they're they're using the
wood ashes there's still not a guarantee
that they're getting the minerals
because the the minerals are not on a
uniform blanket right very good exactly
they're minerals appear in in the soil
like veins of chocolate and chocolate
ice cream as you point out these top 20
longevity cultures the reason why
they're the top 20 longevity cultures
they by dumb luck live in places that
have 40 50 60 minerals in their soil
other people who are putting wood ashes
in their Gardens may only have three
minerals they all die in their 20s and
30s so the Americans might have been
getting or might getting something but
then we stopped using wood ashes now we
get nothing then now we get
[Music]
nothing so you've been in the sment
industry for quite some time right well
commercially yeah commercially uh for 36
years and the reason of course was I
couldn't get manufacturing companies or
other existing supplement companies to
come up with what was needed for
instance you see on TV all the time uh
people are advertising these high-end um
V mineral supplements a multiple they
say our multiple Gives You Complete
Nutrition 28 vitamins minerals we need
90 so so what about the other 22 Yeah
does the does the the medical system
they do they think there
there is what's the general consensus on
vitamins and minerals uh they actually
think there's about 28 and there's
really 90 so it's mainly the minerals
are missing too right I guess then well
or is it bit vitamins well everything
well they're too in fact we were looking
at one very famous vit mineral multiple
commonly used by
chiropractors and brags about Complete
Nutrition and it had five vitamins and
four minerals has nine nutrients we're
going to get the other 81 not the food
you've been taking vitamins and minerals
they've been on the shelf for a long
time obviously the full spectrum is is
important but what else it's essential
what else makes yeah what else makes
your products special okay well that's a
big thing to get all 90 cental nutrients
in One supplement program instead of
having to take 40 different bottles and
and then you're not going to get it
right and so uh what makes our special
is there's over hundred billion dollar
worth of research that was used to
capture all the information we needed to
make these supplements perfect and we've
taken care of all the ratios we've taken
care of everything being in the right
place and so forth the right dosages and
all you have to do is take the
supplement program by body weight which
something the medical system doesn't do
they say if you're over 12 take this if
you're under 12 take that and you could
be a 12-y old only 300
lb okay and so we do it by body weight
that makes this much more accurate and
and one of the reasons why we get such
great results but also because all 90
cenal nutrients are in there in optimal
amounts like our Healthy Start pack is
our basic program it has 245 nutrients
all 90 essential
nutrients and it's it's designed for
perfect biochemical nutrition for 100
pounds of human flesh for a month you
give one of those packs to a 50 PB kid
it's a two-month Supply you give it to a
200 PB person it's a two we Supply you
really need two Healthy Start packs for
200 lb person three Healthy Start packs
for 300 lb and so okay that's quite
simple but some people seem to think
that they need a certain obviously you
need all 90 but they think oh I'm
further deficient in this and they try
to kind of micromanage it I guess you
could say is it that individual or or is
it mainly we just need this kind of
blanket well again you have to
appreciate that all these degenerative
diseases are caused by nutritional
deficiencies so let's say you have
diabetes you take the 90 cental
nutrients with more of the secret sauce
because the secret sauce that one
mineralist missing in diabetes is in
there but if you have type deabes you
don't want to take six months to get
better you want to get better in two
weeks or or four weeks but it's a
constant because their Foods don't have
the nutrition anymore and so people
always ask me well how long do you have
to take this stuff for life it's 90 for
life and that's where we got the 9 for
live part from so if somebody wants to
get started you know what's the best
place to
do getting in at least as a what we call
a preferred customer you get to pay
wholesale prices and you get an auto
ship we'll pay the shipping but if you
want to really become a student of this
information help other people we will
pay you an obscene amount of money okay
get car bonuses and travel and cruises
and all this kind of stuff based on the
number of people you get involved and
how many people you help I mean we have
people who've been with for 10 12 15 20
25 years and some of them are
responsible for 500,000 people some of
them individuals are responsible for
500,000 people individuals are
responsible for a million people how how
does that happen these are high school
graduates these aren't medical people
they high school graduates because we've
trained them through our tools books
like dead doct don't lie epigenetics
rare Oran cures these sorts of things
are CDs dead doal lie U my one of my
favorite ones the newest ones is called
um the CD is called Public Enemy Number
One and the DVD is called somebody needs
to go to jail so we're very excited
about this wow and you don't make any
money from your sales sales of the
products that's correct I purposely set
that up that way because medical doctors
in the beginning we're saying oh you
can't pay attention to that Walla he's a
quack he's one of those charlatans he's
a very good salesman now he'll sell
anything including all these worthless
vitamins minerals so it can make some
money and so I never when I set up young
jity I never took a single penny as a
bonus as a pay anything um the company I
even have to buy my own vitamins
minerals they don't give them to me I
set it up that way and so that takes
away that piece from the doctors they
can't say those things we're publicly
traded so we have quarterly reports we
have annual reports to meet the
SEC um uh requirements and you'll see
very clearly who who the people are who
are getting paid what they get paid what
bonuses they get every year and so forth
and I'm not in there I'm in there as the
founder of the company but the people
who are on the staff who are getting
paid and getting bonuses are listed by
name and their positions and what they
do and so forth I'm listed in there but
because when it comes to how much you
get paid in a bonuses is 000000 z okay
because I have to pay for I set up so I
pay for
everything so one more question Doc and
you mentioned just you set that up that
way just so you wouldn't have people you
know oh you're trying to sell something
right exactly no this is a mission and
of course when you know these things how
could anybody just go and be a doctor
and look at sore throats which I could
do and make a decent living but the
point here is once you're giving this
information and how you know you have
beliefs or not uh in in in God uh it's
one of those things
where you have to say look somehow I've
been given this
information and I cannot sit still and
keep it to myself it's too important for
Humanity and so we created this Mission
we call 90 for life and we um do great
things around the world uh just August
7th of 2015 this year I received
Lifetime Achievement Award for natural
medicine and philanthropy for doing
these things by an associate group with
the United Nations kind of a support
group in the United Nations um because
of all the work we've done in South
America and Africa and Asia okay that's
all the time we have for today doc
appreciate all your all your help your
knowledge and all the things you've done
you've helped a lot of people and that's
we're going to try and do now is is pass
the word on so well thank you Dustin
appreciate your hospitality and thank
you so much for getting the information
out to the people you work with and um
we'll look forward to doing great things
together okay thank you sir see you next
time guys
[Music]
well that was very informative very
educational and and very eye openening
for many I'm sure how did you enjoy that
interview Dustin it was fun it
definitely wasn't enough time I had way
more questions asked but um but yeah
it's doc an extremely knowledgeable guy
and and something we all need to spend
time learning really absolutely and for
those who want to learn more we have our
YouTube channel we have doc has many
resources uh CDs many books all his
research is captured in those uh formats
and there's lots of opportunity as he
travels the world to go and hear him
speak in person so very shortly we are
going to have him speak here in Toronto
and we're hosting the show so we better
go and prepare for that okay yeah and if
you need help with anything guys our
emails and our contact information is
below reach out to us and we'll get you
on a health and nutrition program as
soon as possible yeah absolutely we'd
love to be in touch
[Music]